[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
America hasn't seen a longshot this
impressive since a kid from Atlanta
rapped about an old town road
resurrecting the career of an aging
country singer from Kentucky you'd look
great in the mullet a jheri curl mullet
now this football longshot took down Tom
Brady and the Patriots they bullied
Lamar Jackson and the Ravens and are
trying to dismantle the reigning MVP in
Kansas City this is the B are betting
show presented by the Caesars Palace
sports book I'm your host cabby Richards
and this is my co-host and betting
expert Kelly Cassandra Stewart and we
remember the Titans we sure do and King
Henry is making sure we will not forget
he's reducing like the running back from
that Billy Ray Cyrus era Thurman Thomas
and Emmitt Smith guys now having a
catchphrase is cool that is until the
public starts using it against you so no
Kirk we don't like that we don't like
that Minnesota didn't cover in San
Francisco last week which shot my best
bets to 12 6 and 1 on the season but
today we bounce back weird offerings
championship picks for coming right up
let's go cabbie let's do it
start off with AFC championship two
Titans plus seven at the Chiefs now down
to 51 and a half here at Caesar's Palace
be very cautious here
I understand it's tough to go against
the chiefs of that reverse line movement
has now come down from seven and a half
to the key number of seven
I like the Titans here I did play it in
anticipation this line coming down it
did I'm looking take that better defense
I know this to Derek Henry but the
better defense plus the points I know
Kansas City put up fifty-one themselves
last week but don't find that small
sample size Titans D comes to play
I like the Titans and the under cabby
Derek Henry has rushed for more yards in
the playoffs than his quarterback Ryan
Tannehill has thrown in the playoffs 377
to 160 the Titans are making a case to
return to that run dominant era that we
spoke about earlier and today we have a
special guest who can ball in any era
he's half Ojo he's half cinco he's
hacked half octo Krieg or however Conor
McGregor's said it he's everybody's
amigo ladies and gentlemen Chad Johnson
[Music]
there we go there we go yes when I saw
the UFC 346 beautiful how are you sir
good hi Chad what's up how are you doing
listen I I messed up Connor I know Conor
McGregor gave you a nickname I don't
know how to say to you this is octo is
that Gaylord old stove what is it I
don't know buddy no no I know we're
actually gonna get to it later in the
show
listen although Tennessee pulled off two
stunning upsets in the playoffs to get
to the AFC Championship Game
it was Kansas City's Tyree Hill who had
this to say on Wednesday I feel like
nobody in the NFL can guard any of us is
this bulletin board material a real
motivational factor or are the effects
on the players overhyped by the media in
the fence its overhyped by the media
they really had no effect on players
because you have a job to do once you go
out there one Sunday Monday Thursday
whatever whenever you're playing but
Tyree keel didn't tell a lie here
there's no lie being told here and at
times we need this out of our players
and seeing the things that they mean and
how they feel is that I've always been
politically correct
I like this and so do the bookmakers you
know why because they love that bulletin
board material yeah it's in that public
section and that public perception is
always one of my favorite things to bet
against also the bookmakers have to be
kind of cautious here not to be too off
market but this one's a little off
seasons offering the following prop for
Tyreke Hill over/under seventy three and
a half receiving yards Chad his thoughts
here on this one listen I loved I love
Tyreke I'm kind of scared the last time
you played the Titans he had a big day
which is why this number looks so easy
yes but obviously when you go into a
game and the first you always watch the
film and the first time he played a team
and obviously as he destroy the Titans
for the first time through the air
what is the Titan do defensively common
sense would be the double him so he
doesn't have a day like he did before
I'm scared and I really want to stay
away from that well when these two teams
met and we tend to your point Tyreke had
11 catches 400
57 yards and a touchdown but the Titans
inner winning that game yeah 35 to 32 at
home
now you mentioned in the past chat that
it's very difficult to beat a team twice
yes in a season so does the winner loser
of that first game had the advantage in
the rematch
like we received today that is a great
question with the fact that the Titans
and the cheese have had great momentum
that's obsessed to past six or seven
weeks yeah these guys are gonna sudden
demonstrate is hard to say who has an
advantage at this point when they're
both playing so well offensively and
defensively all right speaking of
revenge games the Packers are blown out
in week 12 at Levi's Stadium where they
have to return today to face the 49ers
this is this seventh time these teams
have met in the playoffs let's break
down that in a sea championship game
Packers now eight point underdogs here
at Caesar's Palace total of forty six
and a half I did play this one as well
in anticipation of it moving off the
seven and a half and it didn't so I was
shocked to see the eight but I
understand the Packers are a public team
so I don't love either side here 312 and
one straight up in their last 16 games
as underdogs so be cautious here
thinking the Packers are gonna get some
revenge here on the 49ers the flip side
here the 49ers ensure they win the time
of possession and games they when they
definitely want it last week versus the
Vikings but we have to give more credit
to their defense and not to that office
49ers one two and one against a spread
the last four games this season when
they've been favored by seven or more
points so tread lightly here not sure
gonna have a best bet on a total in this
one
welcome back Chad Johnson listen you are
you spent some time in San Francisco
this season
certainly Deebo Samuel when these teams
met in week 12 debo had two catches
including this 42-yard touchdown it
looks easy but how how was debo able to
do this I mean it looks easy and Trayvon
Williams been making it easier obviously
he was head up outside giving him the
inside so all he had to do is just run
the over catch it and it's a footrace to
the end zone usually as a DB you want to
play to your help
obviously you're supposed to have help
on the inside the help wasn't there
maybe there's a busted coverage easy
play easy play right out of a slot but
Chad how can we never played in the slot
you know what I didn't have to play in
the slot my people are just that great
you can leave me anywhere on the outside
and now get the job done shut up TJ
Houshmandzadeh who play a functioning
Roush was a slot master many years and
the last time Green played the last time
Green Bay lost was actually on this
field which was in November so how might
the Packers make the adjustments and
turn the game around for them tonight to
adjustment for the Packers the offensive
line has to step up and make sure they
do a job so Aaron Rodgers isn't running
for his life uni has time the second
thing they do need to do is get the ball
to the bhante Adams that offense needs
to run through him it's a pass at the
offense you need to get to your number
one target early and often in order to
have a chance to win this game and I say
to here first where's my camera really I
came right here whichever one this will
get the ball to Davante Adams early all
right we need to Devante here in a
minute but let's finish up with debo he
had 50 receiving yards when these two
teams played in November Ceaser's
coincidentally enough set the line a
little low just 46 half here Chad I'm
not sure who's responsible for that
but even though he's a rookie I'm going
with over and the fact that they don't
think he's proven where they set the
line Matt Lowe is ridiculous
who's responsible raise your hand please
but they are I know what they're gonna
do makers here at caesars I know they
gonna do Gers they're gonna double
Kittel okay you're gonna double kiddo
and he's gonna be all alone
he's gonna eat he's gonna eat okay
unless of course you know Smith and
Preston Smith are just collapsing that
pockets of Jimmy G has no time to throw
that's one thing that the Packers can
they have to defensively that could
happen short end and the last time that
Davante Adams actually recently set a
Packers franchise record with 160
receiving yards last weekend in Seattle
we're seeing two touchdowns here
what makes Devante so hard to stop jack
Devante has the best feet in the NFL
outside of Keenan Allen his ability to
get the top speed and transition and get
in and out of breaks makes him one of
the best as seen here Kelly mentioned it
looks easy but it's not easy because not
very many people I mean I can run this
problem you think you can run this route
but you can't at that speed could you
betray flowers though off the line I
mean in this I'm wrong obviously the two
defendant didn't make it any easier
being that they they should have
communicated a little better so it
didn't come off this clean so you don't
think it was so much Devante as it was
actually is the body as well and also
the DB is messing up the coverage all
right Ceaser's is offering two props for
Javonte this week 83 and a half is what
they said they're receiving yards at and
will he score a touchdown plus 160 so
Chad my question is here the last time
Devante actually got shut down by the
Niners he was double-teamed and Aaron
Rodgers also didn't have a very good
game so that never helps the wide
receivers case your thoughts right
unless Matt I thought in order for them
to win the game it's winner go home okay
you have to get your best offensive
weapon active and get him going early
over and yes he will score so how do the
Packers do that what do they need to do
to get Davante Adams open you know it's
the playoffs
obviously you want to status and run
game with Aaron Jones get him going play
actually yeah that's that's what the
Packers are known for play action and if
you don't you can always start them off
three-step drop
get the ball to him early screens slants
quick outs
just let him feel the ball and get in
the rhythm early this is why Chad's so
great guys we got an expert analysis
each and every time he's on the stage
let's recap Chad's
Hix now he said stay away from Tyree
kill on his receiving yards he wants no
part of that but he does like debo
Samuel over forty six and a half yards
Davante Adams over eighty three and a
half yards and yes plus 165 for Devante
to score a touchdown fan Olson Tony
Stark aren't the only ones cursed with
the knowledge Kelly's here to answer
your pure betting questions in this
week's mind of the public eye RG Chad
asks what are the stats and trends for a
team playing its third consecutive
playoff game on the road we'll shout out
to the New York Giants a few years and
the Ravens who did it last listen this
seems like a narrative I keep hearing
over and over and over again the Titans
a bunch played four straight road games
don't forget week 17 they were at the
Texans but don't buy into that switch
this is not a huge sample size three and
two against a spread since 2006 you
should not be making a play on or
against the Titans just because of the
road game narrative at liam mar 12
claims everyone in their sister will
tease Kansas City and Sims just go down
to six or seven points
so which one busted Kelly Tennessee or
Green Bay you're absolutely right the
books have not moved these lines to
protecting themselves from teasers arm
shocked this though reminds me of that
minus seven and a half with the Saints
wild card weakened versus the Vikings
there is a reason why they didn't need
to protect themselves when the teasers
and also guys we've talked about this
every single week through the playoffs
you just have to pick the winners
eighty-three percent of the time during
the playoffs our audience thinks there
might be an upset this weekend if you're
following us on social at the are
underscore betting you saw this poll
which offered which team team offered
which team offer excuse me the best
value at Caesars current odds to win the
Super Bowl we have the Chiefs plus 115
the 49ers plus 150 Packers plus 750 and
the Titans plus 800 the fans voted and
Green Bay edged out Tennessee with 32
percent of the votes Kelly who do you
think offers the most value here
probably the Chiefs of plus 115 but I'm
not making recommended making a bet
they're the owners why i say that is
because they are a sizable favorite here
they will be a favorite over either the
nine
or the packers depending on who wins
that game but if you like one of these
dogs either the Packers are the Titans
just do a rollover open parlay bet but
one of them on the money line today and
parlay him with the money line in the
Super Bowl
speaking of value it's time for my virus
let's go all right guys as I mentioned
we started the show we've seen kind of a
rollercoaster ride and the roller
coaster has not been a fun one this last
few weeks that is regression man I tell
ya it's been rough but we're gonna get
this one here grab the Packers at San
Francisco and for the first time this
year I'm taking a total I told you guys
I didn't love a side in this game I
actually made this game 45 which is the
key number what this opened up at I
expect a run heavy game Chad Johnson
mentioned Aaron Jones I expect to see a
ton of him against that 49ers defense
it's very gonna get to pass but not so
great against a run we saw last week
Shanahan shut down Garoppolo why because
he was making too many stakes I expect
to see them with a lot of dink and dunk
passes and a lot of running as well what
does all that mean under under under
under let's recap all of my picks for
conference championship weekend these
are less an order of confidence on how
many units I'd recommend you bet on each
school so I've got a 42 play on that
Packers 49ers total I also like the
Packers and Titans against the spread
and we're taking these under and the
Titans Chiefs
even though it looks really really scary
thank you for joining us in the VR
betting show it has been presented by
the Caesars Palace sports book we're off
next Sunday but we're gonna make it up
to you during Super Bowl week you can
catch us Wednesday January the 29th for
a special props props bed show which is
gonna be awesome and we'll be live
during the Super Bowl on Sunday pregame
and halftime breaking down the big game
make sure you're following us on social
@br underscore betting to track all of
our Super Bowl activities our social
team will be camping out of the sports
but betting on every single prop bet on
the board because they're absolutely out
of their minds and letting you fans
aside which prop bet that Caesars will
brand as the PR betting propolis which I
can't you live in Miami Miami yes where
are your seats for the
I had the best seat in the house okay it
was free at home
oh yeah and on the sidelines no at home
at home on my couch watching in peace
and quiet
McDonald's coke with no ice extra cheese
no irons number one so wait if if Diddy
or DJ Calvin or Jamie Foxx oh hey come
down we got it we got a sweater are you
not gonna accept their invite invite us
they're blowing up your phone no the
same discipline that had the last 52
years not to go anywhere I think going
to change because it's Super Bowl 54 and
home is where I'll be watching and I'm
betting the house again maybe you can
now spend your Super Bowl Sunday with
your new friend Connor McGregor who you
met this week last night last night he
gave you a new nickname let's take a
look which I butchered earlier in the
show
not even a stretch
thank you from Ojo Cinco de octo cool
yeah I'm not sure I'll give the nine
change though because one karna says
change your name you know what you do
you change your name okay good idea
all right good luck to all of our
viewers on their bets let's have a
profitable conference today thank you
yeah bring me back
[Applause]
[Music]